so let's continue our discussion of the
fake cancel culture
war and the entire apparatus
that's been built around things like dr
seuss and mr potato head
in the midst of covid economic crisis
inequality lack of access to health care
falling humiliatingly and woefully
behind on climate
on and on i could give you the full list
you know the list
dr seuss and mr potato head are what we
are hearing about in right-wing media
this is something that lachlan marquette
marky i'm not sure i was pronounced
wrote about in axios this morning and
that's a really important aspect of this
the new grift is outrage profiteering
now in a sense outrage profiteering has
been around forever
the idea of if it bleeds it leads is
sort of a nod to outrage profiteering
we know that salacious and controversial
stories in general generate
better ratings than stories about
waterfalls and ginger snaps
i don't pretend this doesn't apply to
the david pakman show if my show was all
about
you know random good news a charity
built 10 toilets in some country this
week
we'd be out of business by now like i
completely recognize that what makes
many shows compelling
is you point to problems you point to
injustices you propose
solutions but uh lachlan markey
in axios outlines something that has
really grown lately
which is the grift of profiting off of
fake scandals and fabricated outrage
where there should really be no
outrage now marky writes about it in
axios
more in the context of political
fundraising and campaigning
this is something i've talked about for
a long time if the country
is more and more in favor of gay
marriage being legal
of abortion being legal than at any
other point in history and it is the
country is as left as it's ever
been on those issues why do right-wing
politicians
keep talking about those issues well the
reason is that those are issues
where if you are opposed to gay marriage
if you're opposed to abortion
you are often viscerally and emotionally
opposed and you are likely to donate
lots of money
to a candidate that shares your view on
those issues so even though the country
keeps moving further and further left
these remain great fundraising issues
for republicans
they profit from generating outrage
often fake
around things like you know democrats
want to abort your kids even when
they're three years old that type of
thing
but not only do republicans line their
pockets with this
outrage porn and profiteering right wing
media does it as well
look at fox news over the last 72 hours
dozens
of stories i'm not exaggerating dozens
of segments
about dr seuss and that's because the
outrage generated by the fake headlines
about dr seuss being canceled and these
being the new book burnings
those headlines generate way more
outrage
and thus interest and twitter shares and
facebook views of fox news clips
than a story about democrats past hr1
which by the way was our lead story
today on the show
and likewise there are now so many
so-called independent right-wing
channels that also
profit from fake scandals that they are
similarly grifting
around this outrage profiteering now i
don't i don't want to start naming names
i don't even want to give them publicity
many in my audience will know
the grift fake outrage channels that i'm
talking about
but this is the new grift and we
shouldn't expect it to go away
for as long as it's profitable now
should our goal be to make it less
profitable well i
you know what if if we fix the problems
we have in this country
the outrage grifting will become less
profitable and what i mean by that is
when we look at how fake stories spread
they spread because they are weaponized
and targeted to
um uninformed people who don't know any
better
and lack media literacy skills with
which they would say
it would be humiliating for me to share
this many people i went to high school
with don't seem to have this ability you
should see what i'm seeing on my
facebook page
um but people if they were more educated
and better equipped with media literacy
skills
they would never share lots of the stuff
that catches fire on social media
because people would say this
is obviously fake i'm not going to share
it so
i don't know that the goal the primary
goal is not
let's make outrage profiteering less
profitable
the goal should be let's fix education
let's teach epistemology media literacy
and give people tools which will
naturally
make this sort of outrage profiteering
less profitable
it won't be unprofitable it it will be
profitable to some degree
because of the tendency toward to to to
where people gravitate to
salacious and explosive stories even if
they're fake but we could definitely
take the win
wind out of it uh by uh better ed with
better education
uh teaching media literacy and equipping
people with the tools that they need to
identify that this is not something i
want to be sharing